Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show, I am Ferren cousin sitting in for David
today, don't forget you can find me on Twitter
at Twitter dot com slash fair and balanced
Facebook dotcom slash, Ferrin Balanced and
of course on YouTube at YouTube Dotcom, the
ring of Fire and YouTube dotcom slash Ferren
Balanced.
The Tampa Bay Times recently had a phenomenal
article based on emails.
They had obtained thousands of pages of emails
actually that detailed the disgusting relationship
between Fox News and Florida Governor Ron
de Santos.
Here's what's happening, according to this
wonderful report, and it's a wonderful report
because they did a good job of digging through
the data, not because it tells us anything
wonderful here, but what Fox News has been
doing since the first week.
After the 2020 election is they have been
promoting Ron Santurce, Florida's governor,
on their network virtually nonstop between
that week after the election in February of
this year, they had him on their network an
average of once per day, one hundred and thirteen
times.
And throughout this time, they were allowing
him, according to the emails, to craft the
narrative.
They were allowing him to pick his own topics
about what he wanted to talk about on the
network, give us the talking points and will
just let you run with it, according to the
emails.
This wasn't hard hitting journalism.
Hell, this wasn't even news of the day.
This was a major the biggest cable news network
in this country.
Allowing the Republican governor of Florida
to come on any time he wanted to spread his
propaganda, and that is exactly what he did.
They made a big spectacle earlier this year
on Fox News about Decencies being down here
when the vaccines were rolling out, had a
100 year old World War Two veteran getting
the vaccine.
Fox News did a whole big special on it.
And Rhonda Santurce was heralded as the hero
of the pandemic, contrasting him, by the way,
with that horrible guy up in New York, Andrew
Cuomo, who lied about the nursing home data.
And what Cuomo did was terrible, not just
with the nursing home data, as we know, but
Florida was doing the same thing.
Yeah, according to a former former data analyst,
Rebecca Jones, who says that she was fired
from her job for not phoning up the Florida
data.
And she has been awarded whistleblower status
by the state of Florida because they believe
there is merit to what she's saying.
But nevertheless, Fox News kept bringing to
Santos on, kept saying he was the leader.
He was showing states how it's done.
His economy was booming.
Cases were low.
Everybody wanted to be run to Santurce.
Willing to bet if you ask them now, they may
have a different answer.
Because things aren't so rosy down here in
Florida anymore, because of Santos's leadership
and his pandering to some of the worst people
in this state who believe that public health
issues are really just personal policy decisions.
Right.
You know, we don't have to make a federal
case of this.
If I don't want to get the vaccine and I don't
want to wear a mask that doesn't affect anybody.
No, actually, it does.
That's why it is public health instead of
personal choice.
But all along the way, according to these
emails that the Tampa Bay Times reviewed,
Fox News allowed to Santos to come on and
spread whatever propaganda of the day he wanted
to spread.
Imagine, if you will, let's say The Daily
Caller got a hold of emails.
From The Rachel Maddow Show.
Or you know what, here's an even better example,
what if you had somebody at CNN, I don't know.
Let's let's name this imaginary person, Chris,
and let's say Chris was reaching out and helping
his brother, a politician, let's say maybe
governor of New York.
And they were actually coordinating on on
strategy and messaging.
Don't you think the right wing would be up
in arms if if something like that were to
happen?
Obviously, I'm being facetious because, yes,
that did happen and yes, Republicans were
outraged that Chris Cuomo was helping his
brother, embattled New York governor, not
for much longer.
Andrew Cuomo.
Helping him craft his narrative, bringing
him on his show even long before any of that
happened, to tout him as how great New York
is doing with the pandemic compared to these
other people.
It's the same situation, folks.
It's the same situation.
People are calling for Cuomo to resign from
CNN or be fired from CNN, and I don't blame
them.
That is a massive breach of the public's trust.
But here now we have the documents that Fox
News was doing the same thing with to Santa.
So where are the calls for his resignation,
huh?
Where are the calls for the heads to roll
over at Fox News?
It's not going to happen because their audience
doesn't care.
Their audience likes it.
But I tell you, folks, this really, truly
is no different than Chris Cuomo propping
up his brother, Andrew Cuomo, it's just as
deceitful.
It's just as disgusting.
Except the Como's are actually getting punished
for it, but to Santos is more than likely
to get rewarded
for it.